grund schluss zu machen sion-stürmer
vorher als erstes und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
bevor wir anfangen zwei dinge ich werde
demnächst eine reaktion serie auf einem
kanal starten so ein eigenes märkischen
format falls ihr jetzt schon videos hab
das nicht merken sollte links im
schatten formular klick auf das formular
tag da den link mit allen werde
eventuell wir sehen ob wir sonst
wirtschaft für irgend welche formate in
zukunft höher ist auch gerne in die
kommentare schreiben und jetzt leute
neue folge stadtrand youtuber wir machen
heute die dümmste version aller zeiten
wir haben zwei kumpels aus dem echten
will dabei hab ich mal gesehen gemacht
und zucker premiere
wie geht es ihr wie gesagt leute heute
noch richtig dumme kategorien wir haben
hauptstadt land in afrika etwas was man
macht und zu chillen youtuber der erotik
verwirrt und grund schluss zu machen
dass unsere kategorien heute leute wir
fangen jetzt an die regeln kennt weil
das gleich an fünf punkte wenn du die
sache sehen und wenn einer als einziger
weißer 20 punkte zusammengezählt kommt
mir weder beste in dieser dümmsten
version ist ob wir alle halten ja maxi
apropos leute ich viel springt aus dem
raum essen
alex ist island länder ist der osten
verbleib von der stadt ist das erste
land dass der osten von elend kurzer
auftritt vom osten von regent moment mal
atlanta ist die hauptstadt zum
bundesstaat georgia aber es sind leider
nicht verkappter ganz klar in afrika
habe ich auch
nicht ganz preiswert und eritrea
schmücken du kleine produkte gegen
lugano dann was noch zu tun ist das gut
das gute mass und diskutieren ist in der
hunger bedürfnisse nein wir ein halter
schwebst und sowas gestern den super
bowl hatte niemand konnte also ich hab
keine die kick aus leben hat mir energie
gegen nachmittag muss das machen dann
chillen ein
nein also wirklich ergeben aber von
einem radlader lukas das e mails checken
leute folgen der steht nicht nur e-mails
checken
da steht einfach ich habe es noch nie
gespielt aber energie haus leben das ist
toll ja auch gekommen
die punkte fünf oder auch noch jemand
energie brauchen die youtuber der erotik
selbe werden ich habe mich selbst wieder
einmal war afrika mittelfristiger für
ok grund schluss zu machen jetzt nicht
geben muss man jedes mal andere theater
essen gibt es also wenn jemand dann
essen denken das ist selten weggegessen
also nicht erst messen
jetzt also hab ich komme gerade nach dem
zusammenschluss ist es ja so dass sich
nur um einen grundschutz machen ist
angeschwollen dass über erotik clips
wieder teilte hauptstadt ist so schlimm
okay aber aber so bundesstaat
hauptstädtischen ab jetzt auch doch
münchen und sogar machen
landeshauptstadt
nein also da kann ich konnte es erst gar
nicht süchtig straßburg und von welchem
land ist einfach die hauptstadt kein
linker schwöre straßburg ist keine
hauptstadt alexa was ist schöner abend
wurden china ist ein pop alexa von alexa
was ist strasbourg straßburg ist eine
stadt im elsass eine landschaft im osten
frankreichs an der grenze zu deutschland
gehört ist einfach
das kenne ich hab sie ist keine
hauptstadt laufen vom bundesheer
washington kommt
ich arbeite gerne vergessen wird ja auch
die rot und schwarz der in afrika
eigentlich war sie werden rund um zu
chillen oder das macht mir der sport
immer sandburg bauen im detail was hast
du denn uni wieder geschafft nicht nur
gefahr ist dann braucht ihr anführer ist
der fußball wirklich etwas kaufen was
war zum ersten mal wasser saufen eine
gute aber deswegen nicht wehren
okay okay jetzt wird er los ich
entschuldige mich jetzt schon mal
verführt die person nicht gleich eine
youtube oder wie heißt ja es ist wahr
wir zwei prozent ist die freude von ok
ich habe auch sagen ihnen geschrieben
von hersteller sorry aber die sache der
sony sony an der stelle sorry ich möchte
dass sony ein echter besonders zu machen
grundschule zu machen
dienstleister setzt du hast nur sechster
stelle ja
so warten dass man sich schlecht über
etwas heiser ist juventus schlussmann
stacks oder zu bestimmen
okay ich habe nichts zu gehen
es locken jetzt will ich dazu nicht
lange zeit ich mir selbst berater der
stadt wittstock i say bereich so ganz
nicht so gut aber einer ausgedachten
hauptstadt kommen die wege auf gott ich
habe mich okay ist dann also ich bin
wenn ich sie ausmacht ist ich habe
glasgow alexa ist klar alle alexander
alexejew der hilfs alex alexa was ist
glasgow glasgow ist mit etwa 600.000
einwohnern die größte stadt schottlands
alexa was ist die hauptstadt von
schottland die hauptstadt von schottland
ist ein barometer kriegshaber nummer
zwei ja denn wenn man die kritik ist
auch die man nicht als erster stopp sagt
nachricht die mich überraschen alter
aber gleich ein echter ist meine wir
müssen es aber echt was überlegen dafür
dass max sind immer sofort stoppen und
das wieder ausgedacht bei hauptstelle
haye könnte ich alle mal finden die hat
nun gehen dann gehe ich jetzt sofort aus
dem video was machst du da hat
irgendwann ein land verlassen
so ging er darin und was macht man nach
weg nicht nur anstrengend ein unikat
kosten der haube sitzt sich sofort für
die scheiße von dir dass du so was sagst
ich hab grad führen würden
kommissionieren ok youtuber der erwartet
ich habe aber das war jetzt ich habe
aufkommen fünf grund schluss zu machen
gemeinheit jemand weiß gemeinde ist ja
sonst so jemand muss junge max
übersteigt ist war halt lieber schlecht
ihr habt somit gerettet aber gleich groß
so dass ich was die hauptstadt ich kann
euch sagen
baden baden ist das band stattdessen
beim er nicht sein dass die hauptstadt
von rheinland pfalz ist ganz klar dass
wir einen stillstand
der samstag brachte jetzt schreibt max
chelseas verpasst du bist meine oma und
mein gott ich bin der boss der bildstock
hauptstadt gerne flecker britische
reiter der welt kannst du niemandem
hauptstadt caracas wir jetzt wieder gut
ich habe am 20
[Gelächter]
alexa in zypern ist super ich bin hier
sehr interviewt die kirchlichen gebnis
oder land in afrika ich komme ich auf
englisch nach den kritischen punkten -10
wahrscheinlich nicht die mathematik
nicht abstellen nicht abgewartet thesen
sind schön selbst gelernt und ich habe
kürzlich vereins und wir legen zu müssen
das war ein punkt jetzt warnt punkte
kinder mit trainings verbessert kann nur
aus schreiben die verschneiten dies war
zu vernehmen ist
ich habe keines erhöhen wenn nicht sogar
wirklich nur wissen wie sich jeder auf
kopfnicken oder youtuber der onyx der
momente spiele ich auch noch mehr
weshalb chili berlin.de niemanden
youtuber der wichtigsten würde ich habe
es ihm besser wenn wir das hier heißt
müssen die meisten gehört so
funktioniert die hat mich selbst
überrascht dass ich jetzt nicht hier bei
youtube irgendwie nicht
lukas coco 000 dollar ich habe hef und
das ist eine gute antwort okay grund
schluss zu machen mit dem computer
chakra schlecht was ihr erstes live von
yoga und shark heißt und so dass sie kam
also nur die energie dem wahlergebnis
schön wenn man schlecht ist fekter hat
dann probier doch mal ich bin kein
scheiß aber ich glaube so ist das mit
den augen stürmer vor ihm
nein das waren 284 augen hat aber selber
von diesem wirklich das ist jetzt aber
nichts was man nicht zusammenkommen
nicht schon weil das auf einmal werden
die einfach ca
ich hab 120 punkte ich habe 110 + zwar
auch gut 430 ps und 175 bis 800 wollte
aber nicht das letzte sein und 150 aber
107 ist deutlich mehr als sonst
besonders an erst- und dass man sie ja
klar
okay das ist gewinner des heutigen tages
gehörte tja ich frage mal kurz alexa
alexa ist 110 + 200 120 ok alexa sprich
mir nach lukas aller kunst und hat in
einem spiel gewonnen alles gemacht
max der beschreibung verlegt die
arbeiten nicht weil ja man kann kann wie
gesagt schickt eure vorschläge von
meinem ex serie und auch gerne vorträgen
für weitere video den
ein portier folge was das geht ab